nous les avons tous vu à l'oeuvre dans
des moments pénibles ou douloureux et
souvent nous les avons admiré et bien
ils en ont assez assez d'être
déconsidéré mal payés négligé alors
qu'elle constitue le pilier de tout
l'appareil de santé publique
les infirmières seront en grève demain
et seul le service minimum sera assuré
dans les hôpitaux
le mouvement lancé par la coordination
des infirmières d'île de france et par
les fédérations santé de tous les
syndicats vise à obtenir la réévaluation
d'une grille de salaires qui démarre à
5500 francs par mois une revalorisation
du statut et de meilleures conditions de
travail ces conditions
christophe martet est allé les vérifier
à l'hôpital saint-antoine à paris dans
le service des grands brûlés c'est lors
que travail catherine fantin son travail
est pénible
les images je vous en prévient aussi
la précision des gestes la maîtrise
technique mais aussi le dévouement
c'est tout cela que les malades attentes
de catherine fantin chaque jour 17
heures elle baigne les grands brûlés et
soignent leur plaît à travailler c'est
dieu parce que vous comme vous voyez il
fait très chaud et c'est presque fait on
est au dessus du bas avec les vapeurs
d'eau chaude travail qui demande
beaucoup de personnel c'est assez long
parce qu'il faut tout défaire 6500
francs par mois
c'est ce que gagne catherine après six
ans d'ancienneté et en plus de son
travail d'assistance ou malades de
préparation des soins elle doit à
stériliser des compresses remplir des
formulaires
quand ce n'est pas faire le ménage
manque d'effectif oblige alors catherine
comme la plupart de ses collègues se
sent frustré le plus difficile c'est de
pouvoir partir le soir de l'hôpital en
disant j'ai fait tout ce que j'ai voulu
comme j'ai voulu faire et on n'arrive
pas toujours pourquoi parce que le
manque de temps le manque de personnel
la surcharge de travail
tout ça fait que quelquefois quand on
sort on se dit
j'essaierai de faire encore mieux demain
les derniers retraits pour le départ oui
nous savons plus les bonnes soeurs
d'autrefois
aujourd'hui nous sommes bien sûr des
infirmières auprès des malades pour les
aider dans leur guérison mais aussi des
techniciennes avec toutes les
responsabilités que c'est un comble j'ai
pas vraiment un élément important c'est
un élément indispensable infirmières et
l'endettement en avoir plus la vocation
je ne sais pas ça existe encore parce
que j'avais envie de m'occuper des gens
malades
ce que je fais moi et au malade
j'aimerais qu'on qu'il y ait des gens
aimables compétents autour de moi pour
me soigner mais c'est sûr que par
moments on a tendance à baisser les bras
à être fatigués se dire on n'y arrivera
jamais mais je crois que de l'énergie
tant qu'on est jeune il faut en profiter
et l'utiliser abolition